c'est dégueulasse
maintenant tu fais pour manger cette
merde tous les jours sérieux quand tu
achètes 30 paquet enfile un gratuit
début je trouvais ça a de la gueule
mais du coup il me restait 30 paquet
je me suis habitué
ce pas que je fasse faire le thème mais
l'entrain stoppard voir c'est quoi être
ouverts demain aller vers ça non merde
je trouve ça bien une sérieuse rue comme
jamais avoir acheté fin
moi j'aime pas du kino québec c'est un
peu sexy et mielleux pour le temps perd
carrément away carrément j'ai remarqué
un truc
ouais enfin les voitures de taux et
comme c'est souvent les meufs mignonne
qui conduisent ouais t'as pas remarqué
non du coup je me dis qu'à peut-être une
chanson à faire là dessus sur genre les
perceptions différentes qua non sur le
fait que ce soit des meufs mignonne qui
font 12 dans les voitures l'auto école
comme elles savent qu'elles sont
mignonnes
si tu veux l on profite pour carottes
les moniteurs elle arrive le jour du
permis minijupe boom l'aîné qui
paniquent ils leur fils le permis tu
vois non c'est ce sont les meufs
mignonne dans les autres écoles
hervé
et les moniteurs reproche est désolé
comment sais tu l'as fier